bir sanal şarkı çıkarmak için 97 yılında
bir ekip kuruluyor işte Japonya'da işte
3 boyutlu modelli animasyon dans ediyor
vesaire
Aslında böyle bir sanal şarkıcı
yapabilir miyiz yaparsak ne olur ya
şarkıcılar çok zor Biz bir sanat şarkıcı
yapalım her şeyimiz daha kolay olsun o
söylesin şarkıları diyorlar ama tabii
tahmin ettikleri gibi olmuyor böyle bir
şey yapmak belki de o süreçlerden daha
zor oluyor ve proje bir süre sonra
kapanıyor 2000'lerde benzer örneklerden
biri bilgisayar simülasyonu haber
spikeri olarak geçiyor bu bu Terim
sürekli değişecek Çünkü şu anda
Gelişmekte olan bir hikaye anlatıyorum
yani bitmiş bir hikaye anlatmıyorum
Aslında o yüzden terimler sürekli
değişecektir sunum boyunca 2000
yıllarında ananova var gazete haberleri
sunuyor işte TTS dediğimiz basit bir
işte sesi bilgisayarda sese yani yazıyı
sese dönüştüren Bir yazılım desteğiyle
basit daha az hareketleriyle haber
okuyan bir sistem olarak çıkıyor işte
büyük paralara satılıyor vesaire ama
sonra bir süre sonra proje çekişini
kaybediyor ve kapanıyor
Buradan sonra bir durgunluk oluyor
vokalovit diye bir yazılım için
İspanya'dan bir ekip Japonya'ya gidiyor
yamayla beraber
Normalde bu insan konuşmasını yani
yazıyı insan konuşmasına çeviren
sistemler var ama müziğe çevirebilir
miyiz diye bir deneme yapıyorlar bu 2004
yılından bir örnek değil vocalayın 5
versiyonundan bir örnek kısa bir şey
dinlettireceğim
[Müzik]
bu teknoloji aslında herhangi bir
notaları olan bir sistemin ya da sözleri
olan bir şarkının sese şarkı sesine
çevrilmesine olanak sağlıyor başta çok
yetenekli değil tabii ki insan
şarkıcılar kullanıyor bu ses bankalarını
yaratmak için bunlarla ilk ciddi örnek
diyebilirim 2007'de miku ile çıkıyor
Çünkü sadece bu yazılımı yapmanın
yetmediğini görüyorlar bunu bir karakter
de yaratmaları görüyorlar karakter
Aslında basit görsellerle başlıyor
[Müzik]
2007'deki durum aslında çok basit bir
oyun yazılım
Uzakdoğu'da çok popüler olan karaoke
için kullanılabilecek bir eşlikçi gibi
kullanılıyor şu Normalde karaoke ile bir
şarkının teliflerini almanız lazım işte
Efendim birine söyletmeniz lazım diye
çaldırmanız lazım sözlerini yazmanız
lazım eşlik edebilecek bir bilgisayar
yazılımı yaparsak Hani bunu bize
İnsanlar istediği gibi düzenler diyorlar
ama bu bir anda bir fenomene dönüşüyor
ve Abdülhamit bu ünlenmeye başlıyor Bu
sefer karakterin geliştirilmesi söz
konusu oluyor 3 boyutlu yapmaları
gerektiğini düşünüyorlar şimdi Hz
Nikon'un 2011'deki bir versiyonundan
kısa bir kare göreceğiz
[Müzik]
bu böyle ilerliyor ve bir anda dünyaya
yayılmaya başlıyor çok farklı
sebeplerden Bu arada tekil bir sebebi
yok O baştaki şarkıcı sebebinin dışında
birçok versiyon olmaya başlıyor ve bir
sanal fenomenler sanal idoller sanal
implansörler gibi kavramlar ortaya
çıkmaya başlıyor
bunlara bakacağız bazıları milyonlarca
takipçi olmaya başlıyor Şimdi bunu iki
tane şeyden ayırmak lazım bir klasik
çizgi film karakterinden de farkı var ya
da işte bir marka ile çalışıyorsa klasik
maskottan ne farkı var aslında bunlarla
mücadele ettiği için uzun süre ne olduğu
anlaşılmıyor birçok insan bunları Kendi
Avatar olarak kullanmaya başlıyor Yani
kendi yüzüyle görünüşüyle barışık
olmayan biri yatıyorum işte twitch'te
bir yayın yapabilmek için bir avatarla
yapmaya başlıyor ve farklı teknikler var
fotorihalistik olanlar var çizgi sitede
olanlar var 3 boyutlu özel estetiklerde
olanlar var Birçok şey göreceğiz
dünyadaki haritası aşağı yukarı bu
Japonya çok önde Bu bir tuber deniyor
bunlara youtuber gibi
daha çok Amerika kıta Avrupa Kupası işte
ve uzak doğuda yaygınlaşıyor uzak doğu
en önde giden yerlerden birisi Ve bu
sanal karakterlerin sayısı artık binlere
2000'lere 10 binlere doğru çıkmaya
başlıyor günümüzde on binlerin üstünde
sanal karakter var ve dediğim gibi
kullanılım amaçları çok farklı yani
kişisel olarak kullanılanlar var ekip
çalışması olanlar var marka çalışması
olanlar var birçok farklı örnek var
Amerika'da 2016'da Brad Lemi kella
karakterini yaratıyor ve bu ilk
İnstagram postlarından birisi Aslında
buradan baktığınızda çok basit bir işte
bir görsel işlemi yazılımı Photoshop
gibi yazılımda bir Fotoğrafın üzerine
bir karakter eklemesi gibi duruyor ve
çok kişi buradaki olayı ciddiye almıyor
ama o seviye zamanla ilerleyerek
[Müzik]
bu şekilde değişmeye başlıyor Şimdi
burada arkadaki teknikleri bir görmek
lazım Bunlar nasıl yapılıyor bir tanesi
şey aslında
bazı kıyafetler var o kıyafetlere
girdiğinizde canlı olarak işte karşıdaki
üç boyutlu modeli yönetebiliyorsunuz
Aslında animasyonla saatlerce uğraşarak
yaptığımız şeyi burada yapabiliyoruz Ama
tabi bu görüldüğü kadar kolay olmaya da
biliyor Çünkü bunu ayarlanması ya da
hatalar olduğunda düzeltilmesi vesaire
gibi şeylerde hala teknik problemler var
ama en azından vücut yakalama için bu ve
başka teknikler de var ilerlemiş olduğum
görüyoruz aynı şekilde yüzün
yakalanmasına benzer şeyler var cep
telefonu içinde bir insan yüzü gör
Arkada da üç boyutlu karakterin yüzünü
görüyorsunuz ve bir cep telefonundan 3
boyutlu bir karakteri
yönetebileceğimize dair fikir oturmuş
oluyor aslında vücut hareketleri vesaire
bunların ikisinin birleştiği örneklerden
birini görelim
bu önemli örneklerden biriydi
ikisini birleştirmek Zorlu Teknik olarak
şu an Kafasında bir telefon görüyorsunuz
kafasına bağlı sistemde oradan yüzer
hareketlerini alıyor demin gördüğünüz
kıyafette de vücut hareketlerini alıyor
ve bunu canlı olarak yapıyordu
Dolayısıyla kalite çok yüksek değil yani
Bu bebeğin yüzünde gördüğümüz kalitede
çok gerçekçi bir şey beklemek Aslında
çok doğru olmayabiliyor
şimdi bu daha da ilerleyecek
sürekli gelişiyor anneyi burada çok
ciddi yatırım yapıyor birçok yazılımda
var aslında blenderda da var benzer
şeyler birçok yazılımda yapılan
teknikler var gitgide kalite artmaya
başlıyor ve canlı etkileşim hızı artmaya
başlıyor
Şimdi burada şeyle kıyaslamayın dediğim
gibi yani bir animasyonlu kıyaslama
almak lazım Çünkü o uzun süre render
alan sistemlerin kalitesi hala çok
yüksek bir sistemdir Bu gördüğünüz şu
anki canlı bir sistem değil Bu aslında
render alınmış işlenmiş bilgisayardan
uzun süre çalışılmış bir yapı Ama
zamanla o canlı performansın buraya
gideceğini 10-20 yıl içerisinde dair
artık netleşme olmuş durumda alanda
şimdi bu kalitenin yükselmesi birçok
sanal karakterleri için önemli olmuyor
Aslında hala çizgi kalitesinde
kalabiliyorlar işte ya kuşi gibi Ve bu
mesela yakışacağı atıyorum ve Twitter'da
var olan çeşitli kanallarda olan 10
binlerce takipçisi olan bir erkek
karakter bunun gibi bir sürü karakter
var
yüz binlerce milyonlarca takipçisi olan
twitch'te düzenli oyun oynayan yayın
yapan karakterlerden tutun Twitter'da
sohbet eden karakterlere kadar birçok
farklı versiyonu görüyoruz Biz bunu Eğer
Mesela en ünlülerinden biri
isminden dolayı buradaki eı konusunu da
aslında bahsedeyim Yapay Zeka birçok
farklı parçada kullanılıyor burada
Mesela 100 yakalamanın içinde var tahmin
etme algoritmalarında var ya da işte
video üretiminde var iskelet
animasyonunda var ama Genelde bizim
anladığımız gibi Yapay Zeka içeriği
üretmiyor bunların çoğunda ama
bazılarında içerik için kullanılıyor ya
bazen kendi konuşma Cevap verdiği
sistemlerde oluyor ama Genelde insanlar
yazılımlar ve donanımların bir üçlü
birleşiminden oluşuyor gizli Noel mesela
çok ünlü bir youtuber aslında
hani birçok şarkısı var vesaire böyle
avamları da değişiyor farklı kullanım
şekilleri de var Mesela işte
İngiltere'de yaşayan bir karakter çok
kısa sesini de dinleteceğim
gördüğünüz gibi farklı bir estetiği var
arkada gerçek görüntüler var önde 3
boyutlu bir karakter var ve normal işte
günlük hayatını anlatıyor Mesela bir
hikaye anlatımı
var bu kıyafet tasarımı tabi çok önemli
gelişmeler yaşadı son 5-10 yıl
içerisinde onun modaya etkisi de var
Pardon
Şuradaki videoyu açayım Mesela neonuri
bir moda ikonu Aslında kıyafetler
tasarım vs ile ilgili festivallere giden
orada o kıyafetleri gösteren o
tasarımları gösteren bir karakter aynı
şekilde şudur böyle şu da gram çok ünlü
bir modeli birçok moda festivalinde
görebiliyorum artık sana karakterleri
Kripto yapılıyor işte onlarda bu
karakterler çıkıp
çalışmalar yapıyor Türkiye de var mesela
su değil Sol altta gördüğünüz yine aynı
modelle ilgilenen karakterlerden biri ve
farklı farklı destekler Bunlar
Türkiye'deki karakterler bir kısmı biz
bunları takip ediyorduk ve Dedik ki bir
süre sonra biz de böyle bir hikaye
anlatabilir miyiz bu anlatmanın içinde
neler çıkar ve oturduk beraber İşte
Zeynep daha Birol Güven tevfikar ve ben
bir strateji koyduk dedi ki bir karakter
yapalım ne olacak nasıl olabilir
Buradaki amaç o kadar net değildi yani
Nasıl yapacağız ve o yüzden bu olmakta
olan hikayeyi Aslında size anlatıyorum
alperayı çıkartırken birçok yüz
tasarladık mesela yüzlere baktık neler
olabilir diye düşündük nasıl bir
karakter olması gerekiyor Ben dünyadaki
ekosistemi yıllardır takip ediyordum
neler olabileceğini O yüzden başta biraz
daha modern gibi kıyafetleri üzerinden
başladı Sonra dedi ki hayır şarkı
söyleyebilir şey yapay Zekai bir şarkı
besletebiliriz sözlerini yazdırabiliriz
bildiğiniz gibi önceden yaptığım benzer
bir robot şaibeniz Yılmaz vardı şiir
yazabilen onun sözlerini kullanabiliriz
ve şarkı arkadaşlara ve çeşitli karma
teknikler kullanmaya başladı aslında
işte stüdyoya gidiyor bir çekimler
yapıldı şarkılar çıkartıldı ve sonra
sosyal medya ile karşılaştı biraz sosyal
medyada özellikle başta çok Deşifre
etmedik neler olduğunu ve kendi doğal
ilişkilerini korumasına çok önem verdik
ne derse desin yorumlarına baktık ve
insanlar gerçekten de bir süre biz
Türkiye'de çok yaygın bir şey var hani
kesin ip var dediğimiz için hemen
tekniğini anlamaya çalışıyoruz Yok yok
bu böyle yok şöyle diye tartışmalar
döndü altında bir yandan işte
İnstagramda bir profili ve paylaşımları
olmaya başladı Twitter'da biraz daha
yazılı bir iletişim oldu ve kavramsal
taraflarını sorguladık demin anlattığım
taraftaki gibi bu sistem içerisinde
Aslında gerçekten insanlar yazılımlar ve
donanımların Beraber karar alması var
Kendi içimizde bir sürü tartışmaya
düştük Alperen ne yapacak nasıl olacak
diye alperen’in gruplarını ciddi anime
şeyleri vardı bu işte Atakan şeyi Hani
göndermesi olan bir işti herkes elini
yanlış elini kullandığına dair yorum
yaptı falanları kızdı vesaire
açıklayamadık henüz yani kalbi orada yok
aslında ve onu temsil etmek için Aslında
böyle bir simetri kullanmıştık
Bundan sonra o kariyeri
şarkıcılığa doğru gitti şarkısı çıktı
vesaire yorumlar aldı ama hikayenin
kendisi bize Aslında bizim kim
olduğumuzla ilgili de birçok şey
öğretmeye başladı bu pandemi sürecinde
ne olacağı İşte bu karakterin Aslında
bunun anlamının ne olduğu pandemi için
Çünkü hepimiz ekranlar arkasına geçtik
Aslında bu karakter sanal karakterlerden
dijital insanlardan çok farkımız
olmamaya başladı şimdi burada önemli bir
tane noktadan bahsedeceğim çok kısa bu
sanal karakterlerin Aslında bu süreçte
öğrendiğim bir şey anlatmak istiyorum
Böyle yavaşça toparlayacağım sanal
karakterler Aslında bize çok şey
gösteriyor biz biz çok ideoller var
takip ettiğimiz ve bir ünlü birisi
milyonlarca kişinin karşısına çıktığı
zaman Aslında bir zorlanma yaşamaya
başlıyor Çünkü o milyonlarca kişinin
ondan beklentisini de karşılamaya
çalışıyor ve bir yandan kendi olmaya
çalışıyor ve böyle bir psikolojik olarak
bir hafif bir problem olmaya başlıyor
Aslında bilenleriniz vardır ünlüler
genelde bir ekiple çalışır ve Aslında o
öndeki yüzleri Bir nevi bir markadır bir
karakterdir ve kendileri olmayabilir
çoğu zaman kendileri değildir yengesinde
biraz daha farklı ama eski nesilde
aslında kurgulanmış bir kişiye döner bir
süre sonra ve bu kişilerde bir problem
yaratmaya başlar ikilik arasında
Dolayısıyla Mesela bu çünkü mesela
alpere neden dijital bir karakter olarak
var bu çok samimi değil sanal bir şey
yapay bir şey dendiğinde şunu görüyorum
Aslında bu daha samimi geliyor bana
çünkü bu yapay olduğunu ve karakterin
kurgulandığını Baştan kabul ediyor Biz
size gerçek insanlara bakıp onların
kurguladığını unutmaya çalışıyoruz
onların gerçek olduğuna inanmaya
çalışıyoruz O daha garip gelmeye başladı
bana o yüzden sanal karakterlerin
Aslında bir nevi bir topluluk sözleşmesi
olduğunu anlamaya başladım yani bu
karakter Aslında onun sevenlerin falan
grub
yorumlarına göre Şekil alan karakteri
ona göre oluşturun onlarla kurduğu
ilişkilere göre giden Çünkü sahiplerinin
birçok Aslında Türkiye'de birçok şehirde
gençlerle farklı ilişkileri var ilk
takipçileriyle Onu ilk değer verenler de
bu ilişkiyi o Samimiyeti kurması
koruması ne demek onların kararlarının
saygı duyması ne demek onların sevdiği
bir yerde onlarla ilişki kuran biri
karşılıklı fayda Nasıl sağlayabilir
buralara doğru gidiyoruz
şey bu arada Yani yakında konseri de
planlanıyor
kontenjanda da sergilenecek bir video
röportajı olacak Daha render'ı taze
bitti o yüzden Video yeni koydum Çok
kısa bir 5-10 saniye kaykayanın
göstereceğim sonra bitireceğim
[Müzik]
Ben dijital bir insanım dünyayı
insanları merak ediyorum sizin gibi bir
vücudum Yok ben bir fikrim Aslında
kavramsal bir yapayım diyebilirim
Evet bu arada ismini geçirmediği ekipte
bir sürü kişi varmış gibi sanatçı çok
değerli insanlar var Hepsine çok
teşekkür ederim bu hayali beraber
ürettiğimiz için paylaştığımız için
benim için her anı çok heyecanlı dediğim
gibi çok iyi anlatamamış olabilirim
çünkü yaşarken anlatmaya çalıştığım bir
hikaye ve buna çok değer veriyorum yani
bittiği zaman kafamıza hikaye başka bir
şeye dönüşüyor Umarım bu süreci
sizde gözlemleyebileceksiniz
Evet ipad'ın bir sözüyle bitirmek
istiyorum Teşekkür ederim